It's
The secret behind secret societies.
Obviously, the secret behind secret
societies is a secret that people don't
want to spread abroad.
And uh this particular topic is so
serious
that I will venture rather to say
nothing, very little, but I'd rather let
history and the quotes speak for
themselves. So it might become tedious
to see quote after quote after quote,
but the fact of the matter is then it's
not me saying it. It's historic facts
being put before you. And then you
decide for yourself whether the picture
makes sense or whether it doesn't make
sense.
Revelation 17:4. And the woman was
arrayed in purple and scarlet colors
and decked with gold and precious stones
and pearls, having the golden cup in her
hand, full of abominations and
filthiness of her fornication.
There's only one church in the whole
world that uses a woman with a cup,
and that is the Roman church. And uh
here is cityi sitta del vaticano using
the woman with the golden cup and she is
called fides
on all their documents. Fides. Now what
does that mean fides?
Well let's go to a masonic source a very
good masonic source written by Albert G.
Mackey the manual of the lodge. Albert
Mackey was a 33 degree Freemason. It'll
become clear as we go through the
lectures what this means. And he says,
"The right hand has in all ages been
deemed an emblem of fidelity. And our
ancient brethren worship deity under the
name of Fides
or Fidelity, which was sometimes
represented by two right hands joined
and sometimes by two human figures
holding each other by the right hand.
Numa was the first who erected the altar
to fides under which the name the
goddess of oaths and honesty was
worshiped. So it means honesty and
fidelity but it is also an image of a
female deity.
Now Revelation 17:5 calls this
institution the mother of prostitutes.
In Revelation 18:7 she says, "I sit as
queen. I am not a widow and I will never
mourn. So she might have lost some
children during the reformation but
she's going to get them back. I am and
there is none beside me. I will never be
a widow or suffer loss of children.
She's going to control the world in a
spiritual sense. That's what this power
says. Now it's interesting that the
Vatican has just recently September 5,
2000 issued this encyclical Dominus
Easus where she says other churches are
no sisters of ours. The Vatican insists
it must always be clear that the one
holy Catholic and apostolic universal
church is not the sister but the mother
of all the churches. Cardinal Ratzinger
said that he's the head of the
Inquisition. They don't call themselves
the Inquisition anymore. They call
themselves the congregation for doctrine
and faith. But it's the same thing. It's
even in the same building.
Now, she's not the mother. She is not
the sister, but the mother of all the
churches. That means all the other
churches are subject to her. Right or
wrong? That's what she says. Now in
revelation 13 verse 1 and 2 speaking
about the same power it says and the
dragon
gave him his power and his seat and
great authority. Now that's a very
wow statement. The dragon gave him the
power. In other words, this power comes
from another source. Now doesn't
Catholicism preach Christianity?
Yes, it does. Doesn't it preach Jesus
Christ as the savior of the world? Yes,
it does. But it also preaches mediation
through
other mechanisms and through the church.
Now it is interesting that in secret
societies there are always two
doctrines.
One for the initiated and one for the
goyam the uninitiated.
And the nights templars had two
doctrines. The one was the inside
esoteric occult doctrine and the other
one was the exoteric the one to the
outside and that was Catholicism. So the
masses received a religion which the
insiders
turned on its head.
Amongst occult insiders,
Lucifer is the true son of God.
Jesus is a second son who was defeated
by the first one who had been thrown
out. So Lucifer is the true luminary,
the victor in the battle and will be the
one who will be worshiped at the end of
time. That is occult doctrine. That's
always been the doctrine of the cabala,
the cabalist doctrine, and it has been
the doctrine ofnosticism.
But of course it's not what the Bible
teaches. But then Catholicism doesn't
teach what the Bible teaches either.
Revelation 17 verses 12 to 14 talks
about 10 horns you saw are 10 kings who
have not yet received a kingdom but who
for one hour will receive authority as
kings along with the beast. They have
one purpose and will give their power
and authority to the beast.
and they will make war against the lamb,
but the lamb will overcome them because
he's lord of lords and king of kings and
with him will be his called chosen and
faithful followers. Now, we're going to
deal with the whole chapter of
Revelation 17 at a later stage. But the
kings of the world here represented by
these 10 will give their power to the
system
just like in the middle ages and enforce
the doctrines on an entire world. Very
interesting. This will be this beast
from the bottomless pit. Now Gary H.
Carr in his work on route to global
occupation puts it this way. He says
there were the ancient mystery religions
which come from Babylon
and uh they were pantheistic of course
which means God is in nature. God is in
everything which in in effect makes us
God then too. This was inculcated in
cababalism was taken over in the
Christian era in what is called
gnosticism
and the knights templars were the inner
secret core that had the ancient
knowledge of the mystics.
This was carried further through
rosacrruianism,
freemasonry and the Illuminati which
according to Gary Carr controls Marxism,
American European secret societies and
political societies, international
banking and the world council of
churches. Now that sounds very strange.
Is the world ch council of churches
controlled by Freemasonry? We'll have to
look into that in some detail. Then of
course you have the entire new age
movement, the theosophical societies,
the many cults and all these things are
all controlled by this mechanism to make
null and void the doctrine of salvation
in Christ alone. That will be the final
battle. And in order to achieve this,
this woman has concealed herself
and has hid herself in a garb of
Christianity.
And people receive the goyam doctrine
and do not know what the inner core
doctrine is. That is quite something.
Well, if we look at 1 Chronicles 16 26,
for all the gods of the people are
idols, but the Lord made the heavens,
tells us that idolatry is quite
something that's rife on the earth. and
uh Nimrod the Lord of heaven, Tamuz the
pagan messiah and Seiramis the queen of
heaven. These are find their origin in
Babylon. And if you go through all the
religions that were that were propagated
in Lebanon, Phoenicia, Babylon, Assyria,
Greece, Rome, Egypt, India, China,
Mexico, Scandinavia, you have only this
same picture under different names. Bal,
Tamuz, Ashtoet, Al, Bakus, Astarta,
Bellowos, Tamuz, Sia, Ishta, Nino,
Hercules, Belus, etc., etc. In Egypt,
Rah, Osiris or Horus, Isis, Hatter,
India, Vishnu, Krishna, Isi or Devaki
and so on and so on. Now
Romanism, the Roman church has taken
this trinity and made it father, mother,
child, which means that they must
elevate the female to the point of
deity. And we'll see how they did that
and how they are doing that with the
sanction of the pope. So the true
trinity and the Roman Catholic trinity
are two different things. For the goyam,
it's father, son, and holy spirit. For
the inner circle, it's father, mother,
child, which is none other than balamus
and asharet. If you want to take it back
to those times,
Jupiter
is the god who is worshiped under Petros
the rock and uh Petri where Peter is
there is the church. So here's another
rock which takes the place of the true
rock. Christianity and the secret
societies. We could then summarize it as
follows. The old Babylonian religion
gave rise to cabalism
via the scenes and others. Nnosticism
came into existence andnosticism
was founded by Simon Maggas. This comes
from no other source than history lamagi
and uh byas Levi. Wow, that's a high
Masonic source. So,nosticism
founded by Simon Maggas. Then
thisnosticism
with its secret doctrine was eventually
over time through many intermediary
organizations carried over to the
Knights Templars. And the Knights
Templars were a group of
a Roman Catholic order if you like that
were set over the temple site to protect
it. And they had strong links to Islamic
societies, the Ismiles, the Karmatites,
the Fatimites, the Duisers, and the
Assassins.
And these are very, very interesting.
And we'll be dealing with them when we
talk about the Islamic connection. what
the secret societies actually teach.
Just like the Templars had two
doctrines, one for the Goyam, the
uninitiated, and one for the insiders,
and the two diametrically opposed to
each other. So the secret societies of
Islam do exactly the same thing, but
that's another lecture. Now, the
Templars, they had their secret inner
information inculcated in the
Rosacrruian
Jesuits.
The Jesuits again formed and created
Freemasonry. And Freemasonry was created
as the Protestant arm of the Roman
Catholic Church. Unbeknown to them,
beguiled, fooled, if you like, into
doing the work that Rome wanted them to
do so that Rome could sit in the
background while Freemasonry did it for
them. And then it wasn't them, it was
them. And it was mainly Protestants that
were doing it. and not Rome. Very
clever. Very, very clever indeed. So now
let's have a look at these Knights
Templars.
Here are some of the presentations,
representations. This is Demaloy uh the
founder of the or not the founder but
the leader at the time of its
dissolution
of the Knights Templars. This is what
their dress looked like if you like. And
that is one of their symbols. It is a
symbol that is used by many churches
today. Did you know that? Many
charismatic churches use that symbol.
That's fascinating.
And uh Jehovah's Witnesses use that
symbol as well. We'll come to that in
another lecture. Now, let's have a look
at what Neestor Webster, Secret
Societies and Subversive Movements has
to say about the Templars. We're not
going to read it all, but uh you can
always if you get the video, stop the
quote. In the year 118,
19 years after the first crusade ended
with the defeat of the Muslims, the
capture of Antioch and Jerusalem, these
groups were founded that were eventually
established as the Templars and they
presented them with a house near the
site of the temple of Solomon, hence
their name, Knights Templars. And they
became very famous and a very powerful
order which controlled all the finances
the financial world. They were the
banking elite of the world if you like.
And then in the the year 1128 the order
was sanctioned by the council of tries
and by the pope. It was a Roman Catholic
order within the church.
Now some years later, October 13, 137,
this order was officially brought to an
end by the king of France because it had
come to light what they were doing. So
it was said the king of France, Philipe
Lebel, had the Templars arrested and the
date was Friday the 13th October 1307.
And since that day, Friday the 13th, is
a day of bad luck for the entire world.
And the charges brought against them
were the ceremony of initiation into the
order was accomplished by insults to the
cross and denial of Christ and gross
obscenities.
Gross obscenities. There were all kinds
of things reminiscent of Sodom that had
to take place there. The adoration of an
idol which was said to be the image of
the true God and that was by forat this
symbol over here of the androgenic male
female deity. The admission of the words
of the consecration of the mass the
right that to lay chiefs amongst
themselves giving absolution and
authorization of unnatural vice. So they
had to to curse the cross, trample upon
Jesus, swear allegiance to Buffet and
sanction this with unusual vice.
It's a pretty serious crime in those
days. So he was sentenced to death, but
the order actually didn't disappear. The
pope was very reluctant to say that it
was so. Masonic ritual includes
references to the Knights Templars. For
example, here secret societies and
subnurvous movements says several
knights who had set forth the rescue of
the holy places of Palestine from the
sarosines formed an association under
the name of freemasons thus indicating
that their principal desire was the re
reconstruction of the temple of Solomon
and you hear a lot about the
today and the story of Israel and all
those interesting things. Now let's go a
little bit into some of the history. I'm
taking you to this beautiful palace.
Where do you think it is?
It's in Jerusalem
and it's Natradan Vatican
and this is where the pope has his
representation in Jerusalem. It's a
palace for a king. There's the Vatican
flag flying outside and uh there's even
a whole lane where you have some
interesting papal artifacts. Now in
Jerusalem, I went to look up the site of
the knights. And here is the knight's
palace. The Latin patriarchy. This is
where the knights templars originally
had a site. And the knights of the
papacy now control this area. This is
their symbol that they use. That is also
the knight's shield which is used by
many religions today. The Rama church
uses that symbol for example. These are
uh the eternal warriors. That is the
symbol that they use. There they are
being they kiss the pope or the
patriarch's uh ring. They are knighted
just like knights and they knight highly
prominent bankers and individuals such
as that. Inside this church you have, of
course, the stature of Jupiter as Peter.
Notice that the foot is well kissed. And
uh I I didn't want to kiss the foot so I
just stood there.
And it is a very important church
because both Pope Paul V 6 and Pope John
Paul II visited this church which is of
course highly symbolic. And there are
the plaques and uh the Latin Patriarch,
the Knights Palace. If you go inside
there's this interesting altar and as
you look at the altar you'll see certain
figures over here. This one over here is
very interesting. Let me get it a little
bit closer. And what do you see? You see
the double-headed eagle, which is also
the symbol that is used in Freemasonry.
So there it is on the altar of the
knights. And what is there on this side?
Two swords helped like a compass.
Fascinating. So there are many many
Masonic fig figures in here. The tail
feathers and the feathers of the eagle.
very reminiscent of what you have for
example on the back of the dollar and
all those other interesting symbols of
the circle with the triangle and the sun
around it and uh the inheritor of the
temper
nuance are the Jesuits. Now the Jesuits
of course
are the ones who behind the scenes
control many things. They were founded
on the 15th of August 1534 by Ignatius
Lala and were sanctioned by the pope on
the 27th of September 1540.
So they were created as it were to stand
against the reformation. They were
designed to destroy the reformation.
Lyola wanted the order to be champions
of Catholic unity and uh of course
submission to Christ's vicar the pope
was absolutely essential. Here you have
the institution of Lyola's organization
by the pope uh on this particular day
and there are some interesting analogies
which we will find here. Here, for
example, there's considerable analogy
between Masonic and Jesuitic degrees.
And the Jesuits also tread down the shoe
and bear the knee because Ignatius Lyola
thus presented himself at Rome and asked
for the confirmation of the order. Now,
everything I say has a quote attached to
it. So, don't say I said it. And if
anybody wants to get angry about
anything that he said, then phone the
people that said it, say said it and be
angry with them. Okay. So, this is what
they did and this is what Freemasonry
does. So, there you have your your nice
little link. Now, who existed first?
Freemasons or the Jesuits? The Jesuits
existed first. Of course,
they were to obey as a corpse.
The reconstitutions repeat 500 times
that one must see Christ in the person
of the general. And even if God gave you
a dog, you must obey him as though he
were Jesus Christ himself. Lyola's
statue in a Jesuit retreat. Lyola in
vision, the society of Jesus constituted
in the chapel NRAAM Natra 1534 now the
chapel of the sacred heart in Paris.
Many many occult o incrustations. And
this is the famous Jesuit oath that each
Jesuit makes when he becomes a Jesuit.
Now it'll tell us something about the
character of the Jesuits. There it says,
"I" and he fills in his name and the
presence of God and all the saints and
all these things swear that his holiness
the pope is Christ's vice regent and is
the true and only head of the Catholic
universal church etc. It also says here
that this power was given by the savior
Jesus Christ. He has power to dispose
heretical kings, princes, states,
commonwealths, governments, all being
illegal without his sacred confirmation
and that they may safely be destroyed.
So a Jesuit swears that if a government
is not subject to Rome, it can be what?
Destroyed.
I further declare that uh I will help
and assist and advise all or any of his
holiness's agents uh wherever I shall be
and do my utmost to extipate the
heretical Protestant or liberal
doctrines. Liberal doctrines are
doctrines where you decide what you
believe. you take the liberty of making
your own choice rather than allowing the
pope to do it for you and that will be
destroyed and all their pretended powers
and that it doesn't matter where you
send me in the world I will obey
and I promise that I will have no
opinion of my own. I will obey like a
corpse and I will make war secretly or
openly against all heretics, Protestants
and liberals as I am directed to do to
extipate and exterminate them from the
face of the whole earth. I will spare
neither sex, age nor condition, and I
will hang, waste, boil, fle, strangle,
bury alive these infamous heretics, rip
up the stomachs and wombs of their
women, crush their infants heads against
the wall in order to annihilate forever
their excribral race. That's a quite a
nice Christian promise. Would you agree?
>> Very Christian promise. Did they do it?
Well, the Valdenzas, they smashed the
children's heads against the rocks to
make the parents resent.
In the Ottoman Empire, that's an
interesting story. In Serbia and in all
those east block countries where they
occupied, they took the children, threw
them in the air, and caught them on the
ends of their bayonets. They were they
were nice people. Now you will say that
was Islam. That wasn't Jesuits. Well,
debatable. We'll talk about it another
time.
And if I cannot do it openly, I will do
it secretly. So that is what a Jesuit
swears. This is the famous Pontipical
Gregorian university in Rome, the most
prestigious Catholic university in the
world. The Jesuits in all their enclaves
have their figures in caves. Now in
paganism all the deities come out of the
cave and they have the letters IHS which
actually stand for Isis Horuset
which is the Egyptian trinity.
They of course tell say it means yes
homminum salvato Jesus the savior of men
but it doesn't it means I Isis Horuset
and their symbol is the triangle with
the allseeing eye in it for this deity.
They also use the pillar
uh the stellar if you like. They have
the symbol of the triangle with the eye
in a circle which is also the symbol
used in the new age movement. And we've
saw that Gary Carr says that Freemasonry
controls the new age movement and the
Jesuits control the Freemasonry or
created it. This is the uh University of
the Jesuits in Prague. On top of it,
they have atlas, not Jesus Christ. If
you go to a more modern Jesuit enclave
like this one in Germany, I visited
this. I'm quite cheeky sometimes. There
I am. And took a picture and inside they
have this picture of Christ. This is not
Christ. This is Atlas holding the world
on top of his shoulders disguised. They
have these symbols up against the wall
there. This symbol is the symbol of
Hermes. If you take away uh the cross
then you have the symbol of Isis. This
is paganism at its best. And these
symbols over here are nothing. Here it
is Jesuit Kia when it was built etc. And
their symbolism ma the M is the Masonic
M the triangle ria the goddess. Here is
a church in Germany a cathedral. Inside
you will see the circle with a cross in
it. The crossed swords symbol of all
symbols used also in Freemasonry.
Now if you go back to ancient Assyria
that was a very prominent cross. It was
the Maltese cross. It comes from ancient
paganism. They have the symbols of this
this star over here. Two stars one over
the other or two crosses one over the
other. They have the compass. They have
the moon with a disc in it or a star in
it which is the symbol that Islam uses.
For example, they have the solar
calendar and the triple crown. All of
these are used by the papacy. Upside
down crosses represent victory over
Christ. Hammers and compasses and
sickles. These are symbols that are
prevalent in the world. There's Jesus
standing above the skull and crossbones
which is a symbol of Jupiter, the god
Jupiter. uh who is a symbol of c who is
Lucifer upside down crosses again this
is a very uh important cathedral in
Europe in Germany where all the
political leaders come together if you
go there you will have Janus the
two-headed one and then you have this
statue so-called of David but of course
it isn't David it is the god Pan because
he has a pan flute in his hand and David
didn't play a pan flute so I went to
Look for the dark side of Pan because
there's a light side and a dark side.
And I found them. There he is. The
hoofed one in the same cathedral. So
they hide their occult symbolism. If you
enter into the hallway, you find this
over here. This is the god Anubis. It's
got nothing to do with Christianity.
There you have him as well. Plus you
have the fernics rising from the ashes.
Plus you have the symbol of Jupiter and
a whole host of other symbols over
there. And in their side chapel you have
all the signs of the zodiac serving the
v various deities like Mars and Aquarius
etc. And the door knob is a yin-yang.
This is nothing to do with Christianity.
They use the symbol of the compass and
Jupiter and the PX symbol over there
which you will find in virtually every
single Christian denomination upon the
face of the earth. The fernex rising
from the ashes, the peacock, all symbols
of Lucifer. Here you have the PX with a
circle with a dot in it. And you say to
yourself, but isn't that a symbol of
Christianity? No, this is a symbol of
Horus.
This has got nothing to do with
Christianity. They use pine cones. Let's
ask Albert Mackey, 33°ree Freemason, to
tell us what the symbol means. The point
within the circle is an interesting and
important symbol in Freemasonry. The
symbol is really a beautiful but
somewhat obsusion to the old sun worship
and introduces us for the first time to
that modification of it among the
ancients the worship of the fallus. So
it's a pretty filthy symbol that that it
deals with male organs. Wow. So that
comes from the horse's mouth. So that's
what it means. Now what's the px mean?
Let's go to the best masonic source in
the world. Morals and dogma page 292.
And in case you don't believe me, I
photocopied it so that you can see it.
There you can see the symbol. Can you
see that? It is the staff of of Osiris.
This is straight from the horse's mouth.
You can't get a better source than this.
This is the highest Freemason who
founded the Scottish right 33 higher
degrees and was what he didn't find
them, but he he he officiated over them
on the medal of Constantinopus inhog
signs whatever inscriptions. And then
some other interesting things. So this
is the staff of Osiris. And then he goes
through the mystic towel and the crosses
and the stars of David. And then he uses
this one as well. Interesting symbol. He
says the vestment of the priest of Horus
were covered with these crosses. That's
a Maltese cross. Remember that I showed
it to you on the Assyrian king. Now who
wears that on his vestments? Well, let's
have a look. Oops, there it is. Who's
wearing it? The Pope is wearing it. So,
what is he? He must be the priest of
Horus. So, to the outside world, it
seems like Christianity, but to the
inner circle, it's our cultism. On the
floor of the the cathedral in London,
you have the trickle, which is the
triple yin yang. And what does that
mean? Well, let's go and ask the sources
themselves. Celtic version of the
yin-yang. That's what it is. The
trickle, the sea, good luck, cauldron,
Celtic goddess, the goddess of wisdom
and witchcraft. Who was enthroned in the
French Revolution? Goddess of reason,
witchcraft, reason, all these things,
same deity.
On the floor of the same cathedral, you
find the mystic towel. What does the
towel represent? Let's ask another mason
Ward. He says it's the symbol of the
male creative side of the deity. Sign
language of the mysteries. So again it
has a sexual connotation. What's it
doing on the floor of a cathedral?
So the Jesuits are the heirs of the
occult religion and they control the
world through their agencies. They stand
in the background create
suborganizations
and everybody thinks they are not
active. Let's ask them themselves what
they believe. Here is the history of the
general of the society of Jesus. These
are all the generals starting with
Ignatius Lyola. They're all listed down
there. We don't have to go through them
all. All the way through
to the present one that rules now whose
name is Peta Huntbach.
Nice German name. It's interesting that
the Germans are very prominent in this.
Peter Hans Kenbach is the head of the of
the Jesuits. Cardinal Ratzinger, another
German, is the head of the Inquisition.
They seem to be pretty much in control.
What does he look like? There he is.
Peta Hans Kulvin.
You're looking probably at one of the
mightiest men's on the earth today. If
not the mightiest, he's the black pope.
Here you have this cave of Lyola. Here
you have George W. Bush and the Pope uh
in audience with each other. And they
don't do anything in by chance. They
just happen to do this exactly under
that picture I showed you where Lyola
receives his commission from the pope.
Now the ceremony of induction and the
extreme oath of the Jesuits. Library of
Congress catalog card. There it is. You
have been taught to insidiously plant
the seeds of jealousy and hatred between
communities, provinces, and states that
were at peace and incite them to deeds
of blood involving them in war with each
other and to create revolutions and
civil wars in countries that were
independent and prosperous, cultivating
the art and the sciences and enjoying
the blessings of peace. to take sides
with the combatants and to act uh
secretly in conse
which you might be connected only that
the church may be the gainer in the end
in the conditions fixed in the treaties
for peace and that the end justifies the
means. Whoa.
This is Hegelian science. two opposing
viewpoints,
dlectic thinking. You war the one with
the other and you rub them up until
nothing is left. It's called thesis,
anti-thesis, and the resultant clash
brings synthesis. That which you want.
Now note that the Jesuit can be very
active on the one side, but he can be
equally active on the other side. So
this is all a process whereby they wish
to attain things. The 30-year war,
what was that about? The aim and the
object was that that war should in truth
become a war of annihilation. Besides,
was it possible for them to allow peace
to be concluded with countries whose
rebellious governments had issued a law
ruling that no Jesuit should ever gain
dared to show his face? Do you know that
the Jesuits were thrown out of virtually
all countries, including Catholic ones,
because they were so divisive?
Catholic kings couldn't even take the
Jesuits and threw them out. If a
Catholic king dared to throw out the
Jesuit, that country was destroyed,
Catholic or not, and the Jesuits are
back. You can take your bottom dollar
for that.
So the frightful responsibility for this
terrible 30 years war must rest upon the
emperor Ferdinandu and his teachers,
rulers and bosom friends, the sons of
Lyola. Every single thing I'm saying is
a quote.
Popery an enemy to civil religious
liberty. In 1550, Pope Julius declared
his claim to universal temporal
political power evidenced by a new coin
he issued its motto having read, "The
nation and kingdom that will not serve
me shall perish." Now, please note that
this is a Roman Catholic statement that
the nation and the kingdom that does not
serve the papacy will perish. What does
that mean in terms of Protestant
countries then? Are they going to be in
trouble? Yes or no?
I would say yes they will be in trouble.
Thomas Ainus the great
philosopher of the Roman Catholic Church
said the pope by divine right has
spiritual and temporal power as supreme
king of the world.
The pope of Rome as head of the papal
government claims absolute sovereignty
and supremacy over all the governments
of the earth. All the governments. All
these quotes are highly potent quotes.
There is nothing mediocre in these
quotes and they come from the highest
highest sources. The right of deposing
kings as is inherent in the supreme
sovereignty which the pope says vice
region of Christ exercise over all
Christian nations. Cardinal Henry
Manning 1892 he was archbishop of me man
of Westminster. So he is in control of
all nations of the world. Now, it's
interesting that uh the Bible tells us
that these words were put on the Christ
uh cross at the crucif crucifixion.
Jesus of Nazareth, the king of the Jews.
You read that in John 19:19,
but the Roman Catholic crucifix has the
words in written on it. Now, if you look
it up in Webster's dictionary, it means
nasarinos rexum.
But in the extreme oath of the Jesuits,
enry means something totally different.
It means
impios which means it is just to
exterminate or annihilate impious or
heretical kings, governments or rulers.
That's an interesting point.
Now another thing that they want to do
is destroy Protestantism. We cherish at
the bottom of our hearts this principle
that whatever does not unite with us
must be annihilated. And we hold
ourselves ready to make as soon as we
shall have the means an energetic
application of this principle.
Protestantism
is already already wearing out and
sinking to decay decay. Yes, we are
destined to insult its last agonies to
march over its broken skeleton and
scattered bones. Oh, let us hasten this
desolution by our strong and united
efforts.
Then already they wrote Protestantism is
becoming decomposed
and we are gaining men of note. This is
extract from the secret plan. Uh those
are the worst of the Catholics, the
inquisitors, the Jesuits. They are
simply the Rish army for the earthly
sovereignty of the world in the future
with a pontiff of Rome for emperor.
Something like a universal surfom with
them as master is what is being planned.
That's all they stand for. They don't
even believe in God. Perhaps the
brothers Karmasov
uh all these quotes. The general of the
Jesuits insists on being master
sovereign over sovereigns. Wherever the
Jesuits are admitted, they will be
master cost what it may. The society is
by nature dictatorial and therefore it
is the irreconcilable enemy of all
constituted authority. 50 years in the
church of Rome written by father
Cheniking.
Ignatius Lyola says himself the power of
the general be will be so unlimited that
should he deem it necessary for the
honor of God he shall even be able to
send back or in another direction those
who have come direct from the popes
so this is a powerful order
Frederick von Hartenber said never
before in the course of the world's
history has such a society appeared the
old Roman Senate itself did not lay
schemes for world domination with
greater certainty of success. They want
world dominion with the pope enthroned
as the universal ruler. The Roman
Catholic Lafayette said, "It is my
opinion that it is that if the liberties
of this country, the United States of
America are destroyed. It will be by the
subtlety of the Roman Catholic Jesuit
priests. For they are the most crafty,
dangerous enemies to civil and religious
liberty. They have instigated most of
the wars of Europe. These are prominent
people speaking.
Morse, he's the founder of the Morse
code, the inventor of the Morse code, he
said. And who are these agents? They are
for the most part Jesuits. An
ecclesiastical order order proverbial
through the world for cunning duplicity
and total want of moral principle. An
order so skilled in all the arts of
deception that even in Catholic
countries, in Italy itself, it became
intolerable. and the people required its
suppression.
That's another prominent man. Archduke
Maximal Francis said, "They have so
constantly mixed themselves up in the
court and state intrigues that they must
injustice be reproached with striving
after universal dominion."
And we could go on and on and on. This
is a very interesting one. This is
Michael Angelo Tambourney 1720. This is
the Jesuit of the general of the
Jesuits. The general speaking to the
Duke of Bronas. And he said the
following. See my lord, from this room,
from this room I govern not only Paris
but China. Not only China but the whole
world without anyone knowing how it is
managed.
Interesting. This is what the Jesuits
themselves had to say. The Pope's
confessor has to be a Jesuit and the
Pope himself has to come to a Jesuit to
confess the Vatican Empire. There all
everything I say is a quote. This here
is Jean Baptiste Jansen. He ruled from
1946 to 1964.
And uh he looks like a charming
gentleman, very cheerful.
Uh
but uh nevertheless
you can see that this photograph was
taken from the Saturday Evening Post
and this is what he is in command of.
And now we will want to deal with these
issues in the next session. He controls
the following secret societies. The
sovereign military order of Malta. So he
is in control of the Knights of Malta.
The Scottish right shrine of
Freemasonry, the Order of the
Illuminati, the Knights of Columbus, the
Knights of the Kluks Clan, Benberit, the
Nation of Islam and its private army
called the Fruit of Islam, the Mafia
Commission, Opus De along with a host of
lesser brotherhoods.
So each one of those secret societies is
controlled by the Jesuits.
How do they control it? And what is
their aim? And who is a member, for
example, of the Knights of Malta? Who
today is a member of the Knights of
Columbus? Who is a member of of Benit?
Who controls the fruit of Islam? Who
controls Opus Day? Who controls Skull
and Bones and all the other secret
societies? And what is their agenda?
That is what we have to find out.
Remember that Rome wants to regain total
dominion and if they are the center of
template theology
then they want to control the world for
the dragon
not for Jesus Christ. The dragon gave
them their power and their seat and
great authority. This is scary.
And this power must be in control in
your country as well as in mine.
But the good news is that Jesus foretold
it. We read it in Revelation and he says
no matter how they confederate, no
matter how they scheme, the kingdom is
going to go to whom? It's going to go to
Jesus. Jesus wins. So there's nothing to
be afraid of. But I will show you these
secret societies in the next session and
I will show you who the members are
as we spoke
in our previous little session. This is
Jean Baptist Baptist Jansen, just one of
the great generals of the Society of
Jesus. He was the leader from 1946 to
1964.
And we mentioned the Order of Malta, the
Shriners, the Order of the Illuminati,
the Knights of Columbus, Kukluk's Clan,
and all these secret societies that are
under the control of the Jesuit general.
Persecution of the Catholic Church in
Germany has been directed only against
those elements which did not entirely
submit to the everinccreasing
centralization of authority in church
and state. So sometimes it looks as if
even the Catholics are suffering but
only those Catholic groups that are not
totally submissive to this system will
be subjugated. Some Catholic orders were
actually opposed to the Jesuits. They
were killed. They were wiped out. In the
French Revolution, the Dominicans had
taken over the Inquisition from the
Jesuits. Boom. They were zapped
and the Jesuits took it back.
Its objective was and is still to
destroy the effects of the Reformation
and to reestablish the Holy Roman Empire
of the German nation.
A greater Germany in other words must be
made again the center of a revived Holy
Roman Empire. Leo H Leman 1942 an
American historian said that. Isn't it
fascinating
that the Russian president
or a Russian president let me put it
that way and many political leaders have
given the assurance that Germany will
once again play a greater role in the
new Europe today. Isn't it also
fascinating that it was a Jesuit priest
father and not Hitler who wrote Minecom?
In fact, you can read it on Minecom
itself.
Now, the SS used this symbol of the
skull and crossbones. What was that a
symbol of? Do you remember?
It was the symbol of Jupiter, the god
Jupiter, the god of death. It's also the
symbol of Osiris who was the god of
death. Anubis is just another form of
Osiris. He is the god of death. He's the
god of the dead. But Jesus says, "I am
the god of the living. I am not the god
of the dead. I'd rather serve the god of
the living." The SS was organized by
Himmler according to Jesuit order
principles. The rules of service
spiritual exercises prescribed by
Ignasius Lola constituted a model which
Himmla strove carefully to copy.
Absolute obedience was the supreme rule.
Every order had to be executed without
comment. Every single statement is being
read from a reputable source.
Again in that wonderful book, The Great
Controversy, we get an idea of the
Jesuits. Throughout Christianom,
Protestantism was menaced by formidable
foes. The first triumphs of the
Reformation past, Rome summoned new
forces, hoping to accomplish its
destruction. At this time, the order of
the Jesuits was created. Notice what
this quote says. the most cruel,
unscrupulous and powerful of all the
champions of popery. Cut off from every
earthly tie and human interest, dead to
the claims of natural affection, reason,
and conscience. Wholly silenced, they
knew no rule, no tie, but that to their
order, and no duty but to extend its
power. We don't have to read the whole
quote. But they made it their business
to destroy Protestantism.
The Jesuit order therefore stands before
us as the embodiment of a system which
aims at temporal political domination
and that over the whole world. You will
say to me surely China will not be
subject. Well, we already wrote read a
quote by the Jesuit general himself
where he says he controls China. Who
controls communism?
The Jesuits created it and therefore
they controlled it. They practiced it in
their in their uh South American
examples where they practiced it before
they instituted it. Very interesting.
This is Count Ferns 1911 German noble
and ex- Jesuit who says this very thing.
At what then do the Jesuits aim?
According to them they seek the greater
glory of God. But if you examine the
facts, you will find they aim at
universal dominion alone. It is they who
rule the world, one quote after the
other. Moreover, the pope has thousands
of secret agents worldwide. They include
the Jesuits, the Knights of Columbus,
the Knights of Malta, Opus D, and
others. The Vatican's intelligence
service and its field resources are
second to none. Even Dave Hunt, American
Baptist historian, says that. So let's
have a look at some of these
institutions. Let's have a look at
Freemasons.
The Grand Design Exposed says, "The
truth is the Jesuits of Rome have
perfected Freemasonry
to be their most magnificent and
effective tool accomplishing their
purposes among Protestants.
Now surely
the members of Freemasonry themselves
must be deceived because if they saw it
they wouldn't do it right.
So actually the order is being used and
they themselves are deceived and only
within the order higher up are those
chosen ones who know and they are
controlled by the Jesuits for Romeo.
very clever, very clever to make
Protestantism do what you cannot do
openly because you have been fingered by
Protestantism as the antichrist.
So this is very interesting. This is a
Templar fortress in and and a church on
the island Mayorca, Spain. And there
again you have the double-headed eagle
and you can go to virtually any church
on that island and you will find the
double-headed eagle over the altars of
these churches.
As I've said I Adam Vice was the father
of Jacobinism
and he is the one who is also the
founder of the Illuminati
from the Jesuit college at Engelstat. It
is said to have issued the sect known as
the Illuminati of Bavaria, founded by
Adam Vicehalt, its nominal founder.
However, seems to have played a
subordinate though conspicuous role in
the organization of the sick. You see,
again, they use a front and a front and
a front.
Now, here are two Jesuit generals. This
one over here is General Ricky
and this is General Leovski.
And very interesting this one over here
1773 to 1840
14 he ruled during the order's
suppression.
Now notice this the Vatican itself
suppressed the Vatican the the Jesuits
between 1773
and 1814.
What happened to the Vatican in that
time?
There was a mortal wound and the pope
was taken into exile and he died. Isn't
that correct? So who gave the mortal
wound to the papacy?
The own order in the own church power
struggle. And he created in his time the
Illuminati was created through vice hop.
And of course he's also the father of
modern communism who with his jackabines
conducted the French revolution. Years
later, Jesuit General Leakovsky with his
Bolsheviks conducted the Russian
Revolution in 1917. And it's identical
to the other revolution and I will deal
with that when I give a lecture on
revolutions and wars and dictators later
in the series.
France's greatest authority on the
Jesuits, Edmund Paris, said the Russian
revolution by eliminating the Tar
protector of the Orthodox Church, had it
not decapitated the great rival and
helped the penetration of the Roman
church, we must strike while the iron is
hot. The famous Russian College of Rome
is created in 1929 and its clandestine
missionaries will take the good news to
its schismatic country. One century
after their expulsion by Tsar Alexander
I, the Jesuits will again undertake the
conquest of the Slav world. And did the
poor Slavic world suffer?
They were slaughtered by the millions.
History will show what happened there.
When Stalin, probably one of the
greatest mass murderers of all time, did
his thing. Frederick the great so-called
of Prussia caused the high degrees of
masonic constitutions of the ancient
right to be revived and he himself wrote
the constitutions under the guide of the
Jesuit general encyclopedia of
Freemasonry Albert G Mackey says that
himself
very interesting and now notice this
this is a source that's unbelievable
this is ISIS unveiled by Blavatski
herself the author of secret doctrine.
She says that the rights are the
offspring of the sons of Ignatius Lola,
the Scottish right and all of these
worked under the instructions from the
general of the Jesuits. So who controls
Freemasonry?
The Jesuits. There's no doubt about it.
Here we have confirmed the induction of
the Knights Templar Mason into the
councils of the said order of knighthood
and hoping in confiding that he will
ever be so demean himself as to conduct
to the glory of IHS the most holy and
almighty God and to the honor of the
mark we do recommend. There's a ritual
in Freemasonry which is totally Jesuit.
So the Jesuits control Freemasonry.
Here's a Freemason uh temple if you
like. It's in Oklahoma.
There is IHS.
This is a Freemason
temple. It's a lodge. There is IHS in
it.
There are still old ladies, male and
female, about the country, who will tell
you with grim gravity that if you trace
up masonry through all its orders, till
you come to the grand tiptop headmason
of the world, you will discover that the
dread individual and the chief of the
society of Jesus are one and the same
person. James Patran, American
historian. There are many that say these
things. Knights of Malta. The Freemasons
are in the foreground while the Jesuits
and the Knights of Malta are in the
background. The Jesuits control even the
Knights of Malta. Now, who are they?
Well, they are headquartered in Rome.
These knights, they used to be on an
island, but besides that, they used to
be a military order. They are still a
military order. They are knights.
They control the banking of the world,
the industry of military complexes of
the world. They oversee Chase Manhattan
Bank with all its branches. They rule
all the intelligence communities, the
KGB, the CIA, and uh all of these things
to restore the dark ages. Everything I'm
saying is a quote. I'm saying nothing.
Don't accuse me of saying anything. I'm
just reading.
Who are they? Well, here's the head of
the Knights of Malta at the moment in
America. This Well, he's dead now. is
Francis Joseph Cardinal Spelman
Cardinals of New York and their
headquarters is St. Patrick's Cathedral,
the Arch the Dieses of the Archbishop of
New York. There are the various ones.
Here's Terrence Cardinal Cook. Then was
Cardinal Okconor and uh currently
Cardinal Archbishop of New York Edward
M. Egan. And let's have a look who the
members of the Knights of Malta are.
That should be interesting. Some past,
some present. General Alava, George
Anderson, Angleton, Azu, Berti, Bobs,
Bonaparte. Does that name ring a bell?
Borgis, Bradley, Brady, Pat Buchanan,
does that name ring a bell?
>> James Buckley, Prescott Bush, does that
ring a bell? Frank Copra, William Casey,
does that ring a bell? The CIA uh Cesner
Cooks Coughlin Loach Gist Stang does
that ring a bell president of the of
France Bill Donovan Alan Dallas Avery
Dallas Edward Egan that's of course the
cardinal himself France Agon John Frell
Flanigan Flynn
Gay Galan Gorman Grace General Alexander
Hag does that ring a bell uh Otto
Fanhapsburg wow Conrad Hilton Hley
Himla. He was Knights of Malta. Jay Ed
Gahoo,
FBI CIA fame. Joseph Kennedy, Ted
Kennedy, Lan Lemon, Lorenza Loose, Henry
Loose, founder of all the great
magazines and Time magazine and all of
them. Great publishing mag magnet. Uh,
Macdonald, Manhattan, you name them. All
of them. O'Neal Otis France Fon Papin
the liate who worked with Adolf Hitler
Peron uh Roco ah the list goes on and on
and on Frank Shakespeare Martin Sha even
Frank Sinatra was a knight of Malta for
interest's sake so there are prominent
men who are knights of Malta now what
about the Knights of Columbus
the founder of the Knights of Columbus
is father Michael McG Gny. He lived a
very short time. Then he died. He was
very young. He died at the age of 38.
There is their emblem. And uh this is
their official home web page. You can
just take it straight off. And you can
see something fascinating. What is that?
Hello.
Do you remember what it is? A little
bundle of rods that you also found in
the French Revolution right there in the
manifest of human rights. What is it?
Fasci. And they've got a wreath around
them. What does that mean? All power in
one man. Who will that man be? Who do
the Knights Columbus founded by a Roman
Catholic priest want to see the power
vested in? The Pope of course. The
Knights of Columbus founded at New
Haven, Connecticut 1882.
Uh it then it was already considered
300,000 strong. Roman Catholics are only
Roman Catholics are eligible. It is
initiative to service in four degrees.
It's the heart and soul of politics. You
cannot get into politics if you don't
have the stamp of approval of these
guys. The fact is well known to
political machines and non-atholic
politicians whose candidates must
receive the approval of Rome and the
Knights before they dare nominate them
for either dogpound or presidency.
The Knights of Columbus principal
business is politics. a Jesuitical
politics. The men minister to the
nations Jeremiah Crowley is the quote.
These are serious accusations. There
they are with their fasi which will
become clearer as we go on and we can
see where we are heading. For today Rome
considers the listen to this. Today Rome
considers the fascist regime the nearest
to its dogmas and interests. We have not
merely the reverent Jesuit father
Coughlin praising Mussolini's Italy as a
Christian democracy but the official
magazine which is civil Catholica. This
is the official Jesuit magazine says.
This is the house organ of the Jesuits
says fascism
is the regime that corresponds most
closely to the concepts of the church of
Rome.
This is scary.
Have you noticed lately that there is
more and more control?
Have you noticed some of these things?
Have you noticed that you are being
treated more and more like uh someone
who has to bow 20,000 times before the
powers and there is the organization
opus day
is a semi-secret religious lay order
with paramount objective is total
support of the papacy and these people
walk around with clamps that tear into
their flesh so that they have constant
pain with every movement to remind them
of their obligation and they have high
high members like presidents for example
of Portugal is a opus day member.
Then we have the skull and bones
organization and who are they? Well,
they have this interesting skull and
bones. What does it represent? You know
that by now. Jupiter. And they have the
number 322. If you look up Genesis 3:22,
you will find now man has become as one
of like one of us
knowing good and evil raising man to the
level of deity. This is Yale University,
the place where they are. Now let's
consult one of the greatest authorities
on skull and bones. That is Anthony
Sutton. Let's ask him where he is.
Educated at the Universities of London,
Gottingham, California. a former
research fellow at the Hoover Institute,
Stanford University as well as economics
professor of Cal California State
University. He had the guts to speak out
and write a book and it cost him dearly.
But nevertheless, let's quote him. There
is the book, Anthony Sutton, America's
Secret Establishment, an introduction to
the Order of Skull and Bones. So that I
don't say it, let's quote it.
Skull and Bones. It's over. It's Bush.
Bush won the election. Let's watch this
video. Yale University. The science of
America's first families confess their
sexual exploits from a gruesome coffin.
In a smokefilled room, a handful of
power brokers manipulate the global
economy. These are the purported
activities of some of America's secret
societies. groups with names like
Bilderberg, Skull and Bones, and the
Trilateral Commission.
The Skull and Bones Society is founded
in 1832 by 15 seniors at Yale University
in New Haven, Connecticut. They
establish a secret society with rules
and rituals that remain unchanged to
this day.
The Skull and Bones initiation ceremony
is said to be held in April in the
tomb's basement. One distinguished
member serves as master of ceremonies.
Once in robe, he is known as Uncle Toby.
The shortest senior is appointed little
devil and dons a satanic costume.
A bonesman with a deep voice is dressed
as Don Kiote. Another is dressed as the
college's founder, Eliu Yale. Still
another is given papal vestments.
It would all be funny if it weren't for
the fact that among the former Bonesmen
are three presidents.
William Howard Taft, George Bush, George
W. Bush, numerous senators and
ambassadors, industrialists like William
Whitney, CIA agents, State Department
officials, and publishing magnet Henry
Loose.
>> Absolute secrecy is also required. In
his 1999 autobiography, George W. Bush
devotes just one sentence to his
membership in Skull and Bones. Quote,
"My senior year, I joined Skull and
Bones, a secret society so secret, I
can't say anything more."
The secrecy, according to some
researchers, is there to protect the
fact that Skull and Bones funnels its
initiates into positions of power and
influence.
The best known Bonesman is ex-president
George Bush, who according to tradition
is supposed to avoid admitting he's a
member.
>> Mr. President, are you member of Skull
and Bones?
>> Leave the room.
>> American Journal got a similar response
when we recently asked George Bush Jr.,
the governor of Texas, about his
membership.
>> Does it still exist? I The thing is so
secret I'm not even sure it still
exists. the council.
>> Okay. So, you'll see that George W. Bush
is a member. They lie in a coffin. They
bow down before a papal figure, swear
allegiance. They do all kinds of weird
sexual things in a coffin, which I'm not
going to uh explain what they do here.
It's pretty vile. And uh these are the
presidents of the most powerful
countries in the world. And they belong
to secret societies such as this. Let's
look at the real
>> now. We're soon to have an election
and uh here is the German newspaper
uh Financial Times Deutschant February
2004 which confirms that uh Kerry the
opposition leader who is going to stand
against George W. Bush is also a member
of Skull and Bones. So really what's the
point in voting if both of them belong
to the same camp? What these people
believe and what they are all about? We
will have to see in one of the next
lectures. The order, what it is and how
it began.
Those on the inside know it as the
order. Others have known it for more
than 150 years as chapter 322 of a
German secret society. That is very
important. In fact, this was discovered
when they broke in and stole some of the
papers at that uh institution.
It uh is officially known as the Russell
Trust of 1856
or as the brotherhood of death because
they serve the god of death who happens
to be Anubis if you like Cyrus if you
like or Jupiter. The American chapter of
the German order was founded in 1833 at
Yale University by General William
Hutington Russell and uh Taft the only
man to be both president and chief
justice of the United States.
Interesting. Now the German order what
does this actually mean? The Illuminati
had its origin at the University of
Englestat and recruits were from the
student encorps. Of course, they had to
be students with high connections, you
know, sons of of uh very high insiders.
The order had its origin in Yale in
1833, but Skull and Bones is a chapter
of a German secret society. So, which
organization does it represent? active
members have enough influence to push
their sons and relatives into the order
and there's significant intermarriage
amongst the families and they fall into
major categories two major categories we
find the old line American families
second families who occupy great wealth
when he's initiated into the order he
says tonight he will die to the world
and be born again into the order as he
will henceforce refer to it the order is
a world unto itself in which he will
have a new name and 14 new blood
brothers also with new names. Now
there's also a British chapter which was
established at Oxford University and all
souls college and the British element is
called the group. So the skull and bones
is not the only one. You have the group
and then you have a European order as
well. So the group links to the Jewish
equivalent through the Rothsch trials,
the inner circle and uh so there is a
worldwide
uh secret organization which has the
highest individual in industry,
government, all facets of life and they
actually are the most prominent rulers
in the world today. And if they are a
chapter of a German society, then they
are the illuminati.
And George W. Bush said that there are a
thousand points of light illuminating
the world at the moment. It's
interesting that the order uh writes
many constitutions. The members write
constitution. For example, Archable
Mleas who is a member of Skull and Bones
or was, he wrote the constitution of
UNESCO.
Now, we're going to have to deal with
UNESCO and find out what it's about.
Churches,
the Union Theological Seminary is under
the control of Skull and Bones,
a very interesting seminary. We'll deal
with these in more detail in another
lecture. Major establishment of law
firms, communications and industry, the
Federal Reserve, and all of these are
controlled by the order. This is how
chapter 322 operates. There's a central
inner core. Notice that this is actually
the allseeing eye, the wedge of the eye,
but that's something else. Uh there's an
inner core, there's an inner circle,
there's an outer circle, there's
Atlantic Circle, the Bohemian Club.
Notice there Bohemian Club, part of
Skull and Bones, Pilgrim Society,
Penumbra Order, Chapter 322 of the
Order, the Trilateral Commission. That's
how it's put together. You could
basically put it this way. Council of
Foreign Relations, United Nations,
Bilderberg's Club of Rome, Royal
Institute of International Affairs, and
the Trilateral Commission with the
Illuminati controlling everything on the
inside forming basically the round
table. Now, you saw that the Bohemian
Club is part and parcel of the issue.
Now, what is this Bohemian Club? Well,
here's the Bohemian Grove.
The August 2, 1982 edition of Newsweek
reported,
this is just another quote, "The world's
most prestigious summer camp, the
Bohemian Grove, is now in session 75
miles north of San Francisco. It's in a
forest. It's a fortress.
But strangely, even fortresses can be
breached. And one
enterprising
journalist managed to sneak in. The
fiercely guarded 278,000
acre retreat is the country's extension
of San Francisco's allmale
ultraexclusive Bohemian Club to which
every Republican president since Herbert
Hoover have belonged. This is just a
quote. This is the Bohemian Grove
ceremony which was photographed or
videotaped very darkly of course very
secretly by one journalist which caused
a major funeral. Now you can see very
little in this light. So I'll explain to
you what's happening there. In this
forest the men
appear naked. Naked. They have to walk
around naked. In fact, some members have
left the society because they're tired
of walking around naked. Now, imagine
every president of the United States has
been a member of the Bohemian Grove. And
you know, just imagine the priests are
dressed in vestments, papal vestments,
and they pay homage to an owl because
the owl sees in darkness.
It has illumination.
They worship nature. They say, "Beauty
surrounds us now and we worship her."
This is nature. It's nature worship and
they honor the owl and bow down to it.
This is paganism at its worst. There are
other rituals which I do not want to
talk about that happen between all these
naked men.
And uh if you read your Bibles, you will
find that those who worshiped in the
groves
were called the perverted ones.
They were people of high position and
were amongst the highest of society. And
periodically a good king came along and
cleaned up. But then they always came
back into power. This is nature worship.
This is pan worship. This is Luciferian
worship and the presidents of the world
are members. Let's look at the Bohemian
Grove video.
>> There's the in his leafy temple.
Let all within the grove be reverent
before him. Lift up your heads, oh ye
trees,
and be lifted up ye everlasting spires.
For behold,
here is Moindu's shrine, and holy are
the pillars of this town.
>> There's the owl.
>> For beauty is eternal, and we bow to
beauty everlasting.
For lasting happiness,
return to one alone, and she surrounds
you now.
Great nature,
refuge of the weary heart. We bow to one
alone.
>> Great nature.
>> He is ever faithful.
Other friends may fail. So must he
become his children.
Little children that believe or ever
doubt her beauty and her faith.
Bohemians and priests. Our funeral
awaits the corpse of care. Prince of all
mortal wisdom,
thou of Bohemia, we beseech thee, grant
us thy counsel.
>> How of Bohemia, grant us thy counsel.
>> Well, that's just a part of the ritual
which shows that it is nature worship.
It is condemned in the Bible. And yet,
who are the members? Let's continue.
This is an article in Mother Jones,
August 18, 1981, volume 6, page 28, and
reports who the prominent members were.
For example, George P. Schultz, Steven
Bchel, uh Gerald Ford, Henry Kissinger,
William Buckley. Can you imagine them
all walking around naked worshiping a
stupid owl? Man, that's so pathetic.
Fred Hartley, Griffin, Haywood, Kors,
Teller, Ronald Reagan, Clawen, George
Bush, William French, Smith, etc., etc.,
etc. It is pathetic.
Modus Operandi of the order. The
activities of the order are directed
towards changing our society, changing
the world to bring about a new world
order. This will be a planned order with
heavily restricted individual freedom.
That's fascism.
And I will show you the papal
encyclicals
that will make your hair stand on edge
as to what is going to happen all over
the world. And believe me, I live in a
country where it's being implemented
and you can see it happening every
single day. It is
scary. But you don't have to be afraid.
If you know why it's happening, if you
do not know why it is happening, you
will despair. And there are thousands
who are putting bullets through their
head because they cannot tolerate it.
4,000 farmers driven off the land and
murdered in my country alone.
They lose everything. They lose hope.
They put bullets through their heads.
They wipe out their entire families
because it's better for them to die than
to live with it.
And you know what? You give a lecture
like this and you show what's behind it
and why it's behind it. And guess what?
They get hope because they see it's not
just them and not something they don't
understand. Once they start
understanding the bigger picture, they
gain hope and they say, "Wow." So, it's
not really the end for us because this
is simply the sign that Jesus is coming
soon and there will be a better kingdom.
Let us give our lives to Jesus Christ
because this world has nothing to offer.
and they get hope. So far than being
negative, they conceive a lecture like
this, for example, as positive and it
has an amazing effect on countries where
this is being implemented this very day.
No constitutional protection if you go
against it. They control education. I'll
show you how in the lectures. Money,
law, politics, economy, history,
psychology, philanthropy, medicine,
religion, media. There is nothing that
they do not control. And remember they
are neither left nor are they right.
So if there are right-wing parties and
left-wing parties they control them
what? Both. That's the Hegelian
principle. That's Hegelian logic.
Remember that both Marx and Hitler the
extremes of left and right presented a
textbook enemies evolved out of the same
philosophical system. Hegelianism. I'm
quoting from one of the greatest
researchers in this field
that brings screams of intellectual
anguish from Marxist and Nazis. Remember
that the not that the the Jesuits were
told that they must serve on this side
and the other side. Remember that. And
create conflict between the sides. This
conflict of opposites is essential to
bring about the change that they want.
Today this process can be identified in
the literature of the trilateral
commission for example where change is
promoted under conflict management. Have
you heard that name before?
Right. Conflict is essential. The state
is absolute. So the state must have
total control. That means the people
must relinquish
their rights to the state. Do you see
that happening in the United States at
the moment?
Absolutely.
So the state requires complete
obedience. An individual does not exist
for himself in these so-called organic
systems but only to perform a role in
the operation of the state. That's
exactly what it was like under Nazism.
Here's Hegel. The two Hegel and Kunt are
the philosophers behind the system. I
was stunned. I was in Europe four weeks
ago in Germany and the leaders, the
presidents of Germany went down and put
down wreaths in front of these people's
graves and said, "Their philosophy has
made the new Europe possible." They
honored them. What a terrible I would
almost say satanic. Well, why not just
say it? Philosophy.
The Illuminati principle that the end
justifies the means
is also the principle of the group and
the order which is skull and bones. That
means you can do anything no matter how
dastardly
as long as you achieve your aim. There's
an outer circle, an inner circle, an
inner core. All of these council of
foreign relations is the outer circle
trilateral commission all of those uh
trilateral commission was founded by
David Rockefeller comprises 200 members
worldwide the Bundy operation uh
activism towards a new world global
order. George W. Bush, who was a member
of Skull and Bones, remember, says that
he's a big idea, a new world order where
diverse nations are drawn together in a
common cause. Only the United States has
both the moral standing and the means to
back it up. So, do you think they're
trying to get all the countries of the
world to come into this system? Yes or
no?
Do you think it's possible that they are
giving their power
to a woman who rides them? Does it look
like it? Who controls them? The Jesuits.
And who do the Jesuits say all power
must be under?
The Pope. Isn't that correct? All right.
So, who do you think would clamor for a
new world order more than anyone else?
Maybe the Pope. Wouldn't that be
interesting?
Well, here he is. New international
order urged for the sake of peace. when
January 3, 2004,
his whole new year's speech
was dedicated to asking for the
implementation of the new world order.
Vatican City, January 1, 2004.
John Paul 2 started the new year by
insisting that peace is possible and
thus a duty. And he called for a new
international order.
CNN, what did that have to say? Pope
calls for a new world order. Thursday,
January 1, 2004.
Vatican City. Pope John Paul rang in the
new year on Thursday with a renewed call
for peace in the Middle East and Africa
and the creation of a new world order
based on respect for the dignity of man
and equality amongst nations.
What did he say? This year, Pope John
Paul directed his thoughts to the
continuing conflict around the globe.
But he stressed that to bring about
peace, there needs to be a new respect
for international law and the creation
of a new international order based on
the goals of the United Nations.
He called for an order that is able to
give adequate solutions to today's
problems based on the dignity of the
human being. This is human rights. on an
integral development of society, on
solidarity amongst nations rich and
poor, on the sharing of resources and
the extraordinary results of scientific
and technical process. You know, sharing
of resources. Have you heard of that
before? Well, there's another term for
it. It's called redistribution
of wealth. Have you heard of that
before?
Right now, let me redefine that for you.
To redistribute wealth means to take the
wealth from the one who has it and give
it to one who has not got it. Is that
correct? Now if you do that, which
nations of the world will be hardest
hit?
>> The Catholic ones or the Protestant
ones?
>> The Protestant ones are the rich
nations. Everywhere you can draw a line.
Now I will show you in the lectures that
come
that there are encyclicals which define
how the redistribution is to take place
and how it is happening and how the
encyclical says it should take place is
what I can see happening in my country
without the government lifting a finger
against it.
It is defined by need as we will see.
Now there's another word for taking from
one who has and distributing it to
someone who does not have.
It's called theft.
Stealing.
Thou shalt not steal, says the Bible.
The Pope in Rome says, "Thou shalt
steal."
He does literally. I'll show you his
encyclical. You will be stunned.
This new world order is going to be an
exciting place.
I don't want much part of it.
Fortunately, my God says
my kingdom is not of this world.
If it were,
they would fight for me. But it is not
of this world. My kingdom
is up there. There where your treasure
is, there your heart will be.
I have managed because I live where I
live to loosen myself from that which I
own because I know that it means nothing
anymore. Do you know that in my country
if you go on a holiday
and you stay away for a while and you
come back and your house is occupied
that you cannot put the new tenants out
even if the house is yours? Did you know
that because they have need therefore
they have the right to take it whether
you own it or not.
And this is not a joke this is a fact.
scary,
but who cares?
I serve a God who has promised the most
wonderful things,
even temporal things to those who serve
him. Wonderful promises. I go to prepare
a place for you, and I will come again
to take you where I am. Also, in my
father's house are many rooms. I go
actually doesn't mean rooms. It means
mansions.
God has prepared things for us which
make this world
sick by comparison. So let them have
their kingdom. Let them have their fun
because my God says this world will come
to an end and the kingdom of God will
reign forever and ever and ever. Don't
miss the next lectures. We're now on a
roller coaster ride that will take you
to exciting places. Thank you for
coming.
Heat. Heat.